today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling viacom
for firing nick cannon after he made
racist anti-white comments i'm we're
canceling viacom for canceling the
cannon
but we're not canceling them for firing
him we're canceling them because they
didn't fire him forth for the anti-white
comments
so let's let's go back and and and uh go
over this again a clip from nick
cannon's podcast went viral
yesterday and in the clip he's mostly
babbling incoherently so it's it's kind
of hard to understand what he's trying
to say
but he does make his feelings about
white people loud and clear
when we talk about the power of
melanated people when we talk about who
we really are as guys and understanding
that
our melanin is so power and it connects
us in a way
that the reason why they fear black the
reason why they fear is because they
the lack that they have of it so then
when you see
what you know dr uh francis c wellsley
talked about
is that fear in that that that genetic
annihilation efficiency
when you have a person that has has the
lack of pigment the lack of melon right
that they know that they will be
annihilated
so therefore however they got the power
they
they they have the lack of compassion
that
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it soul we soul brothers and sisters
that's the melon in that connection so
the people that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm gonna say
this carefully
are a little less and and
and and where the term actually comes
from because i'm bringing it all the way
back around okay
to minister farrakhan to where they may
not have the compassion
or the the when they were sent to the
mountains of caucasus
when they when they didn't have the
power of the sun
that was that the sun then started to
deteriorate with them
so then they're acting out of
fear they're acting out of low
self-esteem
they're acting out of a deficiency
so therefore the only way that they can
act is evil
the only way they can they have to rob
steal rape kill and fight
the flight in order to survive exactly
so then these people who didn't have
what we had and when i say we i speak of
the
melanated people right they had to be
savages
they had to be barbaric they had because
they're in these nordic mountains
they're in these
rough uh torrential environments
so they they're acting as animals right
so they're the ones that are
actually closer to animals they're the
ones that are actually
the true savages okay so
to review white people are a little less
evil savages
barbaric closer to animals
plus we don't have souls compassion or
self-esteem
and we rob kill and rape he he put all
that into
into you know two minutes you have to
sift through a lot of incomprehensible
nonsense to get to it but that's that's
what he was trying to say
he does also appear to think that
melanin in the skin is like some kind of
magical elixir some sort of
supernatural formula that imbues soul
and compassion and other things into
people he sees melanin like it's almost
like he sees it as
what's the thing from star wars the the
thing that jedi have that makes them
that gives them superpowers
might all or mitochondria no it's not
that
uh whatever it is melanin is like that
what the jedi have
and of course that's all
pseudo-scientific inanity it doesn't
make any sense
um at all but the real issue here is the
stuff he said about white people
and the fact that he thinks that we're
evil soulless savages
that that i think is the headline it is
actually helpful though i have to say
i'm actually grateful to the bigot nick
cannon for saying this
because the term racism is thrown around
so much
that you you forget what it means it's
you can easily forget what racism means
because we're calling everything racism
these days and uh you know even
even someone's hairstyle or an art art
curator collecting
art from white white artists you know
we're calling that racist
so after a while maybe you forget it the
the term loses its meaning
and then you see this and you realize oh
okay that's what racism is
that right there racism is a guy
degrading an entire race of people
and outright saying they are less than
him and
savage and evil that is racism and that
is
literally supremacism that is black
supremacism that we're seeing there
to a t textbook racism
maybe not modern textbook racism because
they're changing the definition but any
a real textbook racism right there any
white person who said that
goes without saying if you can even
imagine
a a white person of any prominence
whatsoever
saying anything like that about black
people or any other race
they would be fired shunned canceled
destroyed in a heartbeat without
hesitation without question
and not one person anywhere would defend
them
nor should they nor would i
you see objecting to cancel culture
doesn't mean that we have to take the
position that nobody should ever suffer
any consequences for anything they do or
say
that would be silly of course that's
that's that's not what we mean when we
talk about cancer goals or at least it's
not what i mean
canceled culture is about shutting down
intelligent debate
punishing people for doing and saying
things
that are not actually objectionable and
oftentimes correct
and cancer culture is always is also
disproportionate
so it could be that that someone says or
does something that is objectionable
but the response is totally out of
proportion so for example
some kids playing around with dough at
jimmy john's
become national pariahs that is a
consequence that is
way out of proportion to the crime these
are not public figures
these are just some kids being stupid
uh yeah they're gonna lose their job at
jimmy john's but to have their face
plastered all over the place to be
to be denounced in mainstream
publications across the
the country and the globe way out of
proportion
that's cancelled culture cancel culture
also goes digging for offenses okay the
cancel culture mob
is looking to be offended they're
looking for things
finding things people said and did long
ago to destroy them
a uh you know article someone wrote 33
years ago about women in combat which
also wasn't even objectionable almost
completely
correct but that's how canceled culture
behaves in this case it's completely
different
we have a prominent person saying
something publicly
saying it now not saying it 30 years ago
and what they're saying is wrong and
extremely objectionable and actually
racist by any sane definition of the
term
so this is not yes he should be fired
for that absolutely
and again if it was a white person
nobody would be saying that they
shouldn't
it was a white celebrity it works for a
major media company
and they went out and said about another
race that their savages and evil and
less than him
nobody would be saying don't fire him of
course they're going to fire him for
that
what else is the company going to do
sustain you know the company's not gonna
stand by
they shouldn't have to stand by you for
that
you're the one who decided to come out
and say that and now now you need to
accept the consequences
it's not the company's job to you know
take the slings and arrows for
you being a revolting stupid insane
bigot
but and so he is fired right but the
problem is that he wasn't fired for that
here's the statement from viacom viacom
cbs denounces bigotry of any kind
and we categorically denounce all forms
of anti-semitism
we have spoken with nick cannon about an
episode of his podcast canon's class on
youtube which promoted hateful speech
and spread
anti-semitic conspiracy theories while
we support
ongoing education and dialogue in the
fight against bigotry we are deeply
troubled that nick has failed to
acknowledge or apologize for
perpetuating anti-semitism
and we are terminating our relationship
with him okay
wait a second anti-semitic what it
wasn't anti-semitic
it was it was just it was anti-white in
general it was bigoted against all white
people
it wasn't focused exclusively on jewish
people what are they talking about
well it turns out that nick cannon uh
went on a bit of a
bigotry spree during that episode and
also at one point
said that quote semitic people are black
people
and quote you can't be anti-semitic when
we are the semitic people
when we are the same people they want to
be that's our birthright
and he also said that black people are
the true hebrews
that's what they fired him for even
though that
that what i just what you just heard
there
is while nonsensical and weird and and
incorrect and objectionable
it is way tamer than what he said about
white people in general
i mean remember he called white people
evil savages
for god's sake it literally does not get
more racist than that
that is the height of racist language
you you couldn't you couldn't possibly
be
more racist that's as racist as it gets
but and this is why viacom is canceled
they couldn't bring themselves
to fire nick cannon for anti-white
racism or even
even to denounce it to acknowledge it
it's smacking them anti-white racism
smacking them in the face with a
sledgehammer which these days often it
does in a literal sense as well
but they couldn't do it he's out here
calling white people
soulless barbarians and they don't fire
him for it
they don't even specifically mention it
in their in their announcement of his
termination instead they use the the
semitic comments as the excuse to dump
him
this is how trendy and acceptable
anti-white racism is
you can denounce white people as
sub-human monsters
and you won't lose your job for it you
may lose your job for something else
your company may find some other reason
to dump you because they're afraid of
what you might say next
but that's not going to be the reason
they stay they're going to find
something else
and they certainly won't come out and
say anti-white racism is bad and we
reject it
think about how crazy that actually is
it is now edgy it is controversial it is
provocative it is offensive to simply
say that it's bad to hate all white
people
that statement now is is is like you
know people don't want to say that
it's actually racist to say that i've
been told this directly
that to speak out against anti-white
racism is itself
racist it is racist to be opposed to
anti-white racism that's where we are
and we should also mention that if you
go on on twitter or social media
you're gonna find that there is a lot
of support for what nick cannon said not
just for him not just people saying
oh you let him have a second chance or
whatever people supporting what he
actually said
like yes i agree with it white people
are soulless
barbarians who are sub-human and lack
compassion there's a lot of that
anti-white racism is the only
mainstream form of racism i didn't say
it's the only form of racism that exists
in the world
it's the only kind that is acceptable in
the mainstream not just acceptable not
just tolerated
but oftentimes celebrated
and so if you pretend to be against
racism and fighting racism
but you're not acknowledging this kind
of racism
then you're just a cowardly hypocritical
fraud
and there are a lot of those to go
around these days
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description